Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous.
Il a dit que toutes les conférences
TEDx démarrent par une histoire.
Du coup, je vais vous raconter la mienne.
Cette histoire débute en 2006.
À l'époque, je suis étudiant
et j'effectue mon stage de 2e année.
Je suis en GEA, donc j'ai
principalement un profil marketing,
et j'effectue du coup ce stage dans
une association à but non lucratif
aux États-Unis dans la ville de Seattle.
Ma mission principale,
c'est de créer un moteur de recherche
pour une base de données.
Je n'y connais pas grand-chose en fait
dans les langages de programmation -
j'ai un profil marketing.
Je débute.
Je galère un petit peu.
Et un beau jour vient m'aider un
ingénieur en systèmes d'information.
Il va en fait débugger mon code
et toute la magie
qui va apparaître ensuite
va vraiment m'étonner.
En fait, cette magie va
apparaître au moment
où cette personne va mettre en ligne mon
programme via ce qu'on appelle un serveur.
L'ordinateur qu'il utilise,
ce qu'il renvoie à l'écran, c'est ça.
Je ne sais pas si vous savez ce que c'est,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le système
d'exploitation Gnu Linux.
Plus vulgairement, on appelle ça Linux.
Et c'est vraiment la première fois
que je vois justement linux à l'écran.
J'en avais un peu entendu parler
comme à la météo quand on parle
de mistral et tramontane,
c'est un mot comme ça qui vous parle
mais vous ne l'avez jamais vu.
J'ai eu une révélation.
Naturellement, je vois cet écran et je me
mets à lui poser tout un tas de questions.
Je dis : « Wahou, c'est impressionnant,
ça a l'air super technique.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Tu peux m'en dire plus ? »
Une des questions, c'est :
« Ok, ça a l'air difficile à utiliser.
Est-ce que c'est vraiment le cas ? »
Sa réponse est vraiment
la clé de toute cette conférence -
donc retenez bien du coup
ce qu'il va me dire -
c'est ça :
« Oui, c'est dur,
c'est difficile à utiliser -
il ne parlait pas que de linux,
mais de l'univers du logiciel libre,
dont je vais parler ici -
mais si tu travailles dur, si tu arrives
à comprendre ce qu'il y a derrière,
tu es assuré d'avoir un job
jusqu'à la fin de tes jours. »
En fait, je suis là aujourd'hui
tout simplement parce que
j'ai suivi son conseil.
J'ai atteint ce qu'on appelle l'Ikigai,
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui je vis
de l'univers du logiciel libre,
sachant que je suis quelqu'un
du marketing,
je fais quelque chose que j'adore,
je suis super bien payé :
généralement je travaille une journée
par mois, et mon salaire est déjà fait,
et plutôt un bon.
Aujourd'hui, je fais vivre
toute ma famille grâce à ça.
C'est grâce au logiciel libre
que j'ai pu rencontrer ma femme.
Et par ricochet, que je suis l'heureux
papa d'une petite fille de neuf mois.
Et surtout j'ai l'impression
d'aider le monde entier
et également j'ai eu l'occasion
de voyager à travers le monde -
je continue à le faire -
et de travailler pour les plus grandes
institutions et entreprises
alors que je n'ai que 34 ans.
Cette conférence,
je vais l'articuler ainsi :
je vais définir
ce qu'est un logiciel libre,
ensuite je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est intéressant,
et comment on rentre dans
cet univers du logiciel libre.
Le mot « logiciel libre »,
vous l'avez probablement déjà entendu
et vous en avez
probablement déjà utilisé -
j'ai mis ici quelques logiciels
que vous connaissez probablement,
tel que LibreOffice, tel que WordPress,
tel que gimp ou encore Firefox -
et je vais vous éviter tout le jargon
technique de la définition,
je vais vulgariser tout ça
et le simplifier,
je veux dire plus en mode marketing.
Un logiciel libre est défini
par quatre libertés fondamentales.
La première, la possibilité de l'exécuter
pour toute tâche que vous souhaitez.
Contrairement à un logiciel
propriétaire ou privateur,
vous n'êtes pas régi par des
conditions générales d'utilisation
où vous vous êtes engagé
à utiliser le logiciel juste pour
une fin bien définie par son créateur.
Un logiciel libre, vous en faites
ce que vous souhaitez, ok ?
C'est la première liberté.
La deuxième liberté, c'est la possibilité
d'analyser le code source.
Si on a un profil en marketing ou
qu'on n'est pas dans l'informatique,
quel est l'intérêt de le faire ?
Simplement vérifier s'il n'y a pas
de données envoyées à des tiers.
On va parler de vie privée.
Certains acteurs
vont récupérer des données,
tel logiciel envoie des données
à droite à gauche.
Un logiciel libre, vous pouvez à tout
moment investiguer ce qu'il y a dedans,
chercher et regarder en effet
si ça n'envoie pas des données
à des entreprises contre votre accord.
Troisième liberté, c'est la possibilité
de faire du business avec,
c'est-à-dire de prendre le logiciel, de le
modifier et de le revendre par la suite.
C'est le cas de WordPress.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez.
Il y a encore dix ans,
on n'en entendait pas parler,
aujourd'hui, c'est le logiciel principal
utilisé pour créer des sites web.
Et il y a tout un paquet d'agences,
de micro-entrepreneurs,
qui ont réussi à lancer leur activité
en récupérant ce logiciel,
en créant des sites internet
pour des entreprises
et en les revendant.
Le client derrière récupère un site
Internet qui lui appartient intégralement.
La quatrième liberté,
c'est la possibilité
d'améliorer le logiciel,
c'est-à-dire la possibilité
de le modifier,
de rajouter des fonctionnalités, de
lui faire faire ce que l'on souhaite.
Si on devait comparer le logiciel libre
au logiciel propriétaire et privateur,
imaginez que le logiciel libre,
c'est comme construire une maison.
Vous êtes libre de choisir le terrain, les
matériaux pour construire votre maison,
la taille de votre maison, etc.
Avec du logiciel
propriétaire ou privateur -
ce qui représente pas
loin de 100 % du matériel
et des logiciels que vous
achetez dans le commerce,
on est vraiment sur un cas
où vous êtes locataire.
Vous êtes locataire d'un immeuble,
pour percer un trou, il faut
demander au propriétaire,
vous n'avez pas le droit non
plus de repeindre les murs, etc.
Voilà la grosse différence
entre un logiciel libre
et un logiciel propriétaire ou privateur.
Maintenant que j'ai
défini le logiciel libre,
je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi il est intéressant
de s'intéresser à son univers.
Il y a quatre principales raisons
que j'ai pu identifier.
La première, c'est celle qui
doit le plus vous préoccuper :
c'est le programme Class Code.
Je ne sais pas combien d'entre vous dans
cette salle en ont déjà entendu parler.
Ok, ça craint.
Class Code, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Dès l'âge de 8 ans,
les élèves ont la possibilité
de suivre ce programme.
Tapez Class Code dans un moteur
de recherche et vous trouverez le site.
C'est un ensemble de ressources
pour éduquer à l'univers du logiciel libre
et à la pensée informatique.
Dès l'âge de huit ans,
ils peuvent apprendre
comment créer un site web,
ce qu'est Internet,
comment on crée un robot,
comment on crée son propre programme, etc.
Ce programme m'a fait flipper
et fait revoir ma méthodologie de travail,
toute ma méthodologie
d'enseignement à l'université,
car le jour où j'ai regardé
ce qu'il y avait dedans
et où je l'ai comparé à ce que
j'enseignais à mes étudiants à la faculté
en niveau master 1, master
2, en marketing digital,
j'ai vu que le contenu était le même.
D'accord ?
Un gamin de huit ans aujourd'hui
va ressortir avec les mêmes
connaissances et compétences
que les étudiants que je formais
il y a deux, trois ans -
maintenant, j'ai revu
toute ma méthodologie.
Vous imaginez :
dans dix ans,
quand ces gamins-là vont sortir de l'école
avec toute cette expérience majeure
pour aller travailler,
que pensez-vous qu'il va nous arriver,
qu'il va vous arriver ?
Naturellement, ils vont vous dévorer,
vous êtes les dinosaures de demain.
C'est vraiment super important pour
vous de réaliser cette partie-là,
de regarder ce programme
si vous n'avez pas encore ce bagage
en culture numérique.
La deuxième raison principale
pour laquelle vous devez absolument vous
intéresser à l'univers du logiciel libre,
c'est ce qu'a mis en
évidence Edward Snowden.
Il a mis en évidence beaucoup de choses,
mais notamment le programme Prism :
la NSA a accès à tout un ensemble
de services des GAFAM,
y compris comme on le voit
ici du Gmail, du Skype etc.
Et ce qui est marrant,
c'est que, quand il a ça mis en évidence,
il y a quatre, cinq ans,
le réflexe que le grand public a eu
n'a pas été de dégager Skype, Gmail, etc.
de leur ordinateur, non.
Ce qu'ils ont trouvé
comme moyen de défense,
c'est de prendre un post-it,
de le mettre sur leur webcam pour qu'on
ne sache pas ce qu'il se passe chez eux.
D'accord ? Mais avec ça, en effet,
on ne voit pas ce que vous
êtes en train de faire,
mais naturellement derrière, ça n'empêche
pas de récupérer tout ce que vous dites,
quand vous utilisez ces logiciels.
La troisième raison,
ce n'est pas Greta Thunberg,
c'est principalement l'histoire
du développement durable.
Aujourd'hui, la plupart
du matériel que vous avez
est vendu dans le commerce
avec du logiciel propriétaire.
Un exemple.
J'ai acheté récemment ce boîtier-là.
C'est une prise connectée en Bluetooth
qui permet de contrôler
l'appareil que vous allez brancher
et l'électricité qui passe,
et quand on veut l'éteindre.
Et j'ai contacté le constructeur
de cette prise.
Je lui ai dit : « J'aimerais bien plugger
ma propre application à ton matériel
pour pouvoir contrôler
comme je veux la prise
et non via l'application
sur le Play store. »
Le fabricant m'a répondu :
« Ce n'est pas possible.
Je ne donne pas
la possibilité de le faire,
parce que c'est justement
du logiciel propriétaire. »
C'est assez flippant parce que
le jour où la boîte met la clé sous la
porte, ça file à la déchetterie direct.
On ne peut pas le recycler.
Vous pouvez peut-être
recycler le plastique,
la prise, ça nous fait une
mini rallonge de 5 cm,
mais la partie logicielle en tant que
telle, on ne peut rien en faire.
Donc la déchetterie.
Il y a tout un paquet de matériels
qui sont bons à jeter à la poubelle,
simplement parce que
les fabricants ont disparu
et la partie logicielle n'est
plus du tout accessible.
La quatrième raison pour
laquelle on devrait tous
commencer à faire le nettoyage
dans toutes ces solutions,
c'est toute la partie révolte,
qu'on voit actuellement.
Que ce soit ici les gilets jaunes
ou n'importe quelle manifestation,
le problème de fond, c'est quoi ?
C'est que l'État n'a plus d'argent.
Et pourquoi ?
Tout simplement parce qu'une
grande partie notre économie
tourne sur la technologie des GAFAM.
Regardez autour de vous, rentrez
dans un bus ou dans un lieu public,
les gens sont physiquement avec vous
mais une grande part d'eux
est aussi présente dans l'univers digital
via leur smartphone ou ordinateur portable
équipés des technologies des GAFAM.
Les GAFAM se mettent
de l'argent dans les poches
et plus on utilise ces technologies,
plus notre économie s'appauvrit.
Aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas d'autre choix
que de se mettre devant son ordinateur,
de développer ensemble
avec tous les autres pays,
des briques en logiciel libre
et de nous mettre à construire
notre propre infrastructure numérique.
Tout ça, c'était flippant,
voyons maintenant comment on rentre
dans cet univers du logiciel libre.
J'ai identifié 4 principales manières de
rentrer dans l'univers du logiciel libre
et elles sont toutes complémentaires.
La première, c'est vraiment de réaliser
et ça c'est assez dur - je l'ai
réalisé au bout de dix ans -
c'est de réaliser qu'on est mauvais,
de réaliser que la raison pour laquelle
on n'utilise pas ces logiciels,
c'est principalement parce que
la première fois qu'on les a lancés,
il y a eu un message d'erreur.
Ce n'en est pas vraiment un,
c'est qu'un logiciel libre,
il peut être configuré
de 1001 manières possibles.
Si on n'a pas compris justement qu'on
peut le configurer de manière différente
et en fonction de nos besoins,
il est clair qu'on ne le trouvera
jamais suffisamment instinctif
comparé à un logiciel propriétaire déjà
défini par ce que son fabricant a fait.
Donc ça, c'est la 1e chose à faire.
La deuxième, c'est d'accepter d'investir
et d'investir pas forcément de
l'argent mais d'investir du temps.
De la même manière que lorsqu'on
construit pour la première fois sa maison,
la première fois qu'on se met à innover
dans son appartement, dans sa maison,
le 1er trou que vous avez percé
n'était pas forcément un succès.
Il y a des choses que vous
n'avez pas maîtrisées.
Il va falloir accepter de passer du temps,
régulièrement essayer de comprendre
ce qu'est un ordinateur,
ce qu'est un site web,
ce qu'est qu'Internet,
tout simplement parce que vous allez
utiliser de plus en plus ces machines
et si vous laissez les GAFAM vous bouffer
et continuer à vous imposer leurs règles,
vous n'arriverez pas à comprendre
tout l'univers qui tourne autour.
La troisième chose à faire,
c'est de construire.
Vous ne pouvez pas vous en sortir
si vous ne manipulez pas,
si vous ne créez pas.
Quel que soit votre profil,
il va falloir que vous vous lanciez
dans la création de votre propre site web,
de vos propres classeurs numériques.
Vous ne pouvez pas imaginer le nombre
de start-ups pour qui j'ai travaillé
qui sont pourtant des fleurons de
l'industrie française voire européenne,
et le premier réflexe qu'ils ont,
c'est d'ouvrir un Google drive
et mettre tous leurs documents dessus.
C'est génial : tu envoies tous tes secrets
de fabrication directement à Google
et comment tu veux derrière au final
que la France ou l'Europe
arrive à sortir des champions ?
Impossible puisque c'est ce que
tu es en train de faire.
Tu es enseignant
et tu prends un Google drive,
et tu mets les notes de tous tes étudiants
à l'intérieur d'un classeur.
Le jour où Google veut recruter,
il a accès à l'ensemble des notes,
il sait qui sont les meilleurs profils,
Les plus mauvais ? Il le sait aussi.
C'est de la logique.
Quand vous utilisez un logiciel,
à qui il appartient ?
Et est-ce qu'il y a un intérêt
à piocher dedans et à l'analyser ?
Voilà.
Ça, c'est la partie construction,
vous devez construire vos propres trucs.
Et en effet c'est un combat
de tous les jours.
Monter son propre serveur,
ce n'est jamais fun.
Moi, ça me faisait flipper.
Au final, avec le temps, on y arrive.
La quatrième chose qui est selon moi un
des facteurs de succès du logiciel libre,
c'est de partager, c'est de contribuer.
Aujourd'hui, pourquoi
ces logiciels paraissent instinctifs ?
Simplement parce que toute
la documentation en ligne
l'est par les personnes
qui ont créé ces logiciels,
et eux ils sont de l'univers du technique.
Donc naturellement si pour ceux
qui ne sont pas de l'univers technique,
vous n'expliquez pas
quels freins vous avez rencontrés,
si vous n'expliquez pas à d'autres,
si vous ne prenez pas soin
des anciennes générations,
comment voulez-vous que ces anciennes
générations arrivent aussi à passer le cap
et arrivent à comprendre
comment les utiliser et les manipuler ?
Et c'est l'effort que j'ai fait cet été :
j'ai accepté par exemple de pas
me payer pendant deux mois,
et pendant 2 mois, j'ai créé cette
plateforme pour mes semblables -
mes semblables,
c'est les profils en marketing,
la FLOSS marketing school -
et l'objectif justement, c'est de
former gratuitement, librement,
tous les profils en marketing digital
voire tout individu à travers le monde
sur l'utilisation de ces technologies
mais à des fins de marketing digital.
Comment, au lieu d'utiliser Google,
on peut créer
son propre moteur de recherche
et arriver à comprendre
son fonctionnement.
Même chose avec l'analyse d'audience
ou l'e-mailing etc.
C'est ce projet que j'ai créé.
Et pour conclure, je vais vous montrer
simplement quelque chose de tout simple.
C'est une maison.
Cette maison a été construite
par mon grand-père,
qui nous a quittés il y a deux ans,
et en fait lors de la cérémonie d'adieu,
la prêtresse a dit la chose suivante :
il avait souhaité passer ses derniers
jours, ses dernières heures,
dans la maison qu'il avait
construite de ses propres mains.
Et cette phrase-là, elle m'a marqué
parce que mon grand-père
n'était pas maçon.
Il était dessinateur industriel.
Et je pense que cela doit être
le même cas pour vous,
pour ceux qui ont des grands-parents,
c'est de se dire qu'à l'après-guerre,
il y avait tout à reconstruire.
Et même si ce n'était pas leur travail,
ils sont allés au charbon,
ils ont appris justement à prendre
soin d'un jardin, à créer un mur,
à choisir les bons composants
et à faire avec ce qu'ils avaient,
pour construire la maison.
Aujourd'hui la situation,
c'est la suivante :
on a un univers qui est plutôt favorable
et pour construire notre univers,
c'est un simple ordinateur.
Et on a peur de notre ordinateur
parce qu'au 1er message d'erreur :
« C'est trop technique, j'ai
besoin d'appeler un développeur. »
Pour terminer,
je voulais simplement vous dire
que notre futur, votre futur,
il est face à vous en fait
tous les jours,
c'est votre écran d'ordinateur.
Il ne vous reste plus
qu'à le changer, ce futur.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)